امن المواطن قد يكون مفتاح اختراق
الجمهوريين لولايه نيويورك الملونه
بالازرق
استراتيجيه الحاكمه الديمقراطيه الحاليه
كيف هوكل القائمه على مهاجمه منافسها
الجمهوري للزلدن بصفته مناهضه للاجهاض
ووضع نفسها كخط الدفاع عن حق النساء
بالاختيار لم تعمل وفقا
الجريمه وايضا اخفاقات اداره بيدن التي
تؤرق الناخبين ليحاكي بها سكان نيويورك
لوقف زياده الجرائم الخطيره
وبالفعل اظهرت احدث استطلاعات الراي تقارب
السباق بين المرشحين مع التقدم هوكول
بنقاط قليله على منافسي هذالدا
ارقام منخفضه بشكل غير مريح للديمقراطيين
بعد عقدين من الهيمنه وتنذر باحتماليه
حدوث تغيير بملامح ميول الولايه
الديمقراطيه ما لم تنحرف حملات المرشحين
عن مسارها الاساسي المتمثل بالقانون
الاجهاض ومساءله ترامب على الاقل في
الاسبوعين الاخرين وذلك في محاوله مترنحه
اخيره لجذب الناخبين الى صناديق الاقتراع
وتعزيز موقعهم
يعني
لمنصب حاكم نيويورك الديمقراطيين
طين لا سيما ان فوزه يتطلب الحصول على 30%
من الاصوات في مدينه نيويورك مع كل
الديمقراطيين والفوز بسهوله في المناطق
الواقعه شمالا وهي وصفه استعصت على
الجمهوريين منذ فوز جورج باتاكي بولايه
ثالثه عامه 2002